thank you very much for being on the
program today uh mr lewis
late night parties people getting so
drunk that they're spilling wine around
the room they're throwing up they're
getting into fights
and this was going on in downing street
while ordinary people were following the
rules that those in number 10 had set
should the prime minister now resign
no the prime minister's take
responsibility for everything that was
happening number 10 and he has uh
apologized for that i think he's set
that out properly and rightly so
obviously these were things that
happened over a two-year period much of
which obviously some of these events it
turns out looking at the report the
prime minister wasn't even in number 10
at the time but he has already taken on
board some of what was set out in sue
gray's interim report and as she's noted
in the report today has already been
implementing the changes that were
needed to be seen at number 10 to change
that culture and change the structure
you say that changes have been made and
i'll be honest i'm struggling to see
exactly what changes and who is taking
responsibility for it the prime minister
isn't resigning the head of the civil
service simon case isn't resigning
martin reynolds the man who invited 200
people to a party and then emailed to
say we seem to got away with it he seems
to be being moved to another plum job in
the civil service so how is this taking
responsibility
well first of all the prime minister has
publicly taken responsibility for this
he made that point uh very specifically
uh on the floor of the house of commons
as well just by staying apologized
away from them
well
but he has taken responsibility he has
said he accepts the findings of the
reports he's accepted the findings of
the
the police's uh investigations as well
and he has changed the team at number
ten there's been a very very big change
in the team at number 10. not least of
all the chief of staff obviously as you
say other people have left number 10 and
different people have come in there has
been a changing structure then actually
sue's great report uh it today itself
outlines that she acknowledges that
there has been change that she thinks is
delivering on what she's setting out and
then it's a change which has changed
just to come back in just a comment
just to come back in the head of the
civil service simon case isn't resigning
martin reynolds the man who sent out an
email to 200 people is being moved to
another job we understand the prime
minister isn't resigning there may be a
change in personnel in number 10 but it
seems to be completely unrelated to who
actually should be taking responsibility
to some of what's going on
well there has been as you say change at
number 10 so quite substantial change at
number 10 in the team that have come in
there now
and are working through and getting on
with the job of working for the country
and delivering for people across the
country on a whole range of issues and
that's where the focus um has been and
as i say over the i think it is right
that the the sugro report itself
recommended that there was change there
was clearly a need for some cultural
change there are some of the things in
the report today do make difficult
reading
and that's why i think it was right the
prime minister set out as he did on the
floor of the house today
you tweeted to say the pm has apologized
unreservedly and is already implementing
the recommendations for change we must
now get on and deliver for the british
public as they rightly expect
what is your evidence that the british
people do want you to just get on with
things and deliver rather than taking
responsibility and for the prime
minister to resign well there's a a
number of things come together i think
look first of all we have got an
unprecedented situation in this country
we're still recovering from the
pressures of covid and what that's done
to our economy and our wider society
obviously the fallout from the war in
ukraine and dealing with those issues
but have also to knock on effect in
terms of food prices and also energy
prices where we're seeing this global
pressure on energy prices this global
battle with inflation that is having an
impact on people across the country i
think these are issues that people want
a government to be focused on and
delivering what they elected us to do in
2019 but i go further than that and say
to you over the last
few weeks obviously we've had low
collections one of the things i've seen
when i've been out and about talking to
people in those elections and actually
talk to people outside of election time
as well as i do with my own constituents
is people wanting to see us focused on
the issues that are affecting their
everyday lives and working particularly
at the moment to ensure that we get
some structure around what is happening
in ukraine because people do care about
what's happening ukraine a sovereign
democratic country and that they believe
we're doing the right thing by
supporting the people of ukraine and the
ukrainian government but also dealing
with those issues such as the pressures
on cost of living that they're seeing
through the pressures on inflation
particularly the challenges around
energy that people are seeing and that's
what i'm getting in my mailbox is what i
get when i talk to people on doorsteps
that they want to see us dealing with
those core issues that's what they
elected us to do and that's what they
want to see us deliver on of course you
know i'm not saying that people don't
care about all those things but people
can also care about integrity in public
life and whether or not parties were
going on in number 10 while everyone
else was following the rules and the
reason i asked for evidence is because
the evidence that i'm seeing you know a
snap pole by yougov showing three and
five britons say boris johnson should
resign compared to just 30 percent who
say he should stay in the result in the
role has the prime minister saved his
job but lost the next general election
for you
uh i'd say so i didn't catch all of that
but i think i i got enough of the back
end of your question there to know what
you're saying look as we all know from
uh years of experiencing yourself as a
journalist in politics and myself as a
politician is polls are a snapshot in
time uh the reality is the the votes
that count are what we see in a
generation i've said before quite openly
i think that boris johnson is the right
man to be leading our country i think he
will lead the conservative party into
the next general election and i do think
he will win it and i think he'll do that
because people will see that when they
elected us in 2019 they did that on a
manifesto that we will have delivered on
and we will be delivering on the things
people elected us to do but also look at
those big decisions that the prime
minister's had to make whether it's
through the decisions around covert or
the decisions uh with the support for
ukraine and i think people will see over
the months ahead as we supported people
through kobe we're determined to do
everything we can to support people
through that global challenge of
inflation and i think getting those big
decisions right are another reason why
people will put their confidence in the
prime minister again to see us through
the next general election as well
now there's one thing i am i'll be
honest a little bit puzzled about today
sue grey didn't investigate the alleged
party in the prime minister's flat that
happened on the 13th of november 2020.
now this is when five aides joined the
prime minister's wife at 6 pm the prime
minister then joined at 8 p.m food and
alcohol were available and then it went
on into the evening
in your view was that breaking the rules
oh well the the police have looked at
this and sue gray as uh well you've seen
my sister grace reports for greater than
the police have not fined
investigating that thing's penalty
notice that he has already outlined so
clearly well the police who looked at
everything and the police and sue grey
had access to far more uh details and
documentation than either you or i have
had and i respect the decisions they've
come to and i think we've got a and i
have absolute confidence in the police
to have done a thorough job as they
always do so
i'm not talking about the police view
that those rules were not broken in that
one i'm not talking about the police
investigation i'm talking about the
sugre investigation and i'm just really
puzzled as to why she didn't investigate
the one thing the one event that could
have caused the most problems for the
prime minister the alleged party that
took place
inside his own flat now we know boris
johnson had a meeting with sue gray
before the publication of this report
instigated by number 10.
did they discuss at all whether or not
the flat party would be investigated
well as sue grows put in her report
obviously she's been she's had access to
all the information that she has asked
for and has had information she said no
paul that she hadn't i saw where people
have come forward with information
obviously the police had the ability to
look at anything and everything they
wanted to look at they said they have
clearly only issued one fixed penalty
notice to the prime minister as he has
outlined um and he has dealt with that
look as i say i don't know the details
of private meetings what i can say is
somebody who has worked with sue gray
both when she was dealing with uh ethics
and probity in the cabinet office and in
her
role here in northern ireland and her
role now
in the department looking at issues
around the union sugree is an
independently minded very very focused
professional civil servant and she will
have done whatever she feels was
necessary to produce report that she
thinks is right i don't think anybody
could question either her
professionalism or independence and i
trust the judgment that she has come to
i think she's come and written a report
that does make difficult reading places
i think that's why it's right that the
prime minister outlined as i said today
not only his apology but has taken the
action that was recommended in her
interim report as well in that meeting
between the prime minister
and sue gray
is it correct that he suggested that she
could drop the report i i wasn't in a
meeting between the premises of growth
so i'm not a comment on a meeting i
wasn't in i think the reality is sue
grey's report is out there sugrose
published liverpool i don't believe for
one moment the prime minister would have
interviewed in any way in the report he
has been very clear i have to say the
conversation i've seen him outline both
publicly and and and i'm sorry let me
just finish sophie promises always very
clear he wanted to see these reports
come through both sue grey's report and
the police investigation come to its
completion so that people would have the
full facts out there to be able to draw
their own conclusions of him to be able
to outline and answer those points as he
has done
both with the interim report with sue
gray the fixed penalty notice and that
final report and the statement he's
given today i'll be honest i feel like
i'm struggling to get the full facts of
everything that went on
do you know you say you don't know what
happened between the prime minister and
sue gray at that meeting have you not
asked the question have you not tried to
find out because it does feel you know
if this is a meeting set up by number 10
uh ahead of the publication no no sophia
i can't answer very directly no i
haven't no no no no sophie it's very
simple no i haven't because i have to
say having worked both with the prime
minister who i know what here where his
focus is on the issues that affect
people across the country those domestic
issues people want the prime minister
dealing with around the economy and
around those international challenges
that we're facing and actually have as i
say having worked with sue gray on a
range of issues over the years i have
absolute respect for sue gray's
independence sugree will not be um
somebody who shies away from taking
tough decisions and giving tough
messages to people when she needs to and
i think she's proven that for her career
and with the report today
okay so you you're very upfront and
honest full credit to say you haven't
asked what went on in that meeting
between the prime minister and sue gray
is that because really you don't
necessarily want to know the answer
because if you perhaps didn't know the
answer it would be a lot more difficult
to come on programs like this and defend
the prime minister's conduct
look sophie i'm always happy to come on
your program in any situation i've come
and talked to you about a whole range of
issues and challenges over the years and
no that's not the reason at all it's as
i just outlined you look i know the
prime minister i work with the prime
minister i know sue graham i've worked
with sue grey in a number of different
jobs in government over the years and
i've i had no question or doubt
whatsoever that sue gray would put out
the report that she wanted to put out
with no fear or favor to do the right
thing she is a very professional civil
servant and she's somebody who will
always speak truth to power i've
experienced that i've seen her do that
and it's why she's such a talented civil
servant okay as you say um you have come
on a programme my program over the years
defending
boris johnson defending theresa may as
well when you're working under her
definitely one of these people who comes
on to you know give the defensive of the
government so putting that aside i just
want to talk to you as a person for a
minute
what would you say
to the people in britain many of whom
made huge huge sacrifices during the
pandemic some of them who lost loved
ones and they weren't even allowed to
see them in hospital when they were ill
or when they were in care homes
what would you say to them when they
look at the report
they look at what was going on in number
10. no that's a very fair question
what would you say
no it's a it's a
it's a very fair question and obviously
i have spoken to people who have been in
that situation both people i know and uh
through work as well and no i absolutely
understand that the upset the anger the
frustration people have of what they uh
could see was going on and what was
happening at number 10 why it's not
acceptable that's why i think it was
right that the prime minister took those
actions obviously the number 10 is a is
not just a it's a place of work but it's
also a home and it's a it's one of those
places you know sophia that uh that the
the space in there is used across number
10 consistently but that's no excuse for
particularly as i say some of the
difficult things to report today and one
of the comments in there i think the
prime minister raised on the floor of
the house today as well around how some
of the staff have been spoken to by
other people it's just not acceptable
and that's why it is right the promise
is very clear about that apology both to
people generally across the country and
to those affected by this
situation both in terms of how they've
been treated and dealt with in number 10
and
the perception that has created across
the country so i do understand that but
that doesn't move away from the reality
that i know and having worked as a
member of the cabinet through carved
we've been having in the work i've seen
a prime minister focused on whether it's
widely for the uk or here in northern
ireland his focus has always been on
doing the right thing to deliver for
people across the country and and that's
why i think he has got those big
decisions right brandon lewis thank you
very much for being on the program today
you're very welcome thank you